Jessica Alba flaunts her incredibly fit  figure in Hawaii Jessica took a family  vacation to lay Hana on Wednesday and  she looks stunning ageless and amazing  to 35 year old actress flaunted her  toned physique in a pineapple printed  tory burch string bikini complete with a  matching coverup and straw hat the mom  of two looked flawless out in the water  giving us more reason to work on our  summer bods she also shared adorable  photos via Instagram of her crew  exploring the tropical destination and  cruising on a boat here's Jessica  sharing a seaside smooch with her  husband cash Lauren and the couple's  little girls honor and Haven had a few  more kisses for their father  Jessica captioned the cute pic quote dad  smooches so grateful for my family